to baseball now it was a wild ride for
opening day yesterday there were a lot
of changes to keep fans and players safe
yankee stadium among several ball parks
that operated at 20 percent capacity
fans had to show proof they either got
the vaccine or tested negative for covet
19.
the coronavirus is already throwing a
curve ball at the season
the washington nationals were forced to
cancel their opener against the new york
mets
after at least one player tested
positive major league baseball is
planning to play a
full 162 game season with fans in the
stands good to see baseball back
mother nature threw a wild pitch for
some teams though yesterday did you see
this
the cleveland indians play the tigers in
detroit
yeah that's snow only lasted the first
couple of innings
over in boston the red sox actually
postponed their opener against the
baltimore orioles because of
rain even though they didn't play it
made for this really memorable on-air
moment with a sports reporter
at our sister station in boston look at
this
you want to hit you want to hear
something funny
the ducks left because the wind picked
up
and then you guys come to me live and
you can see what's happening right now
i'm barely holding on to this umbrella
like mary poppins
that poor guy look at his scripts
they're drenched he's still trying to
read them
the wind picked up his umbrella yeah
flipped inside out
but this man still went on with his live
report even though there was no game
how dedicated is that sherry he is
hanging in there isn't he